how tall are you 6'4 when I leave here
I'm gonna go that tall guy is a nice guy
that's it in my mind you're here with
six foot four guys then I might add
something else to this six foot four
black well-dressed right this is how we
framed you but you're a pilot right how
long have you been a pilot ten years now
a decade never say 10 years always a
decade it sounds different it has more
gravitas how many hours have you flown
well it's 5 600. close close to six
thousand close on six thousand hours
when I open a conversation if I'm you
this is my opening intro hi my name is
amandi I'm a pilot close on a decade of
experience I've got over six thousand
hours in the air and I'd like to talk to
you guys a bit about my new startup
that's a logistics have I got your
attention now I'm not a six foot four
world dressed black guy